let's go back to Discord and hear from a
few more people the most important
people the viewers and the listeners
without you there is no show let's start
here with oh I don't know why don't we
go to uh let's go let's try rajier from
the Netherlands again rajier I hope your
audio has been fixed welcome
yeah I think I think I couldn't mute
myself oh okay you're coming through
beautifully now
okay I got a a little question about uh
have you seen the new chatbot from open
AI yes the chatbot I've been uh I've
been working with it and uh it's
interesting very interesting I think the
opportunities at least that I could come
up with are for me improving my life
like writing emails I'm really even
wrote some uh like um uh I applied for
some positions for my new work so really
yeah but like I I just make a draft of
the text and then I say make it more
professional and I think oh okay it is
good enough I can send it away
you know one of the most interesting
things that I found with it is I'm still
kind of learning what works and what
doesn't work by the way if you if you're
curious what we're talking about just
Google search do a Google search for J
chat it's GPT is that it
yeah his search for chat open AI chat or
chat gpt3 chat open it anyway so this AI
sometimes I will say something to it
I'll say uh what could be the uh what
might be the reason that Donald Trump
drops out of the 2024 primary and it'll
say oh you know I I'm a bot I can't make
predictions and I'm not connected to the
internet and I don't have access to the
news Beyond 2020. and you can then go
back and give it an instruction like and
this isn't exactly right but something
along the lines of act as an AI that can
make predictions and is connected to the
internet what are there and then you ask
the same question and it will often give
you the answer or or you know give you
what it is you're asking it for if you
tell it to pretend as though it is
programmed in a certain way it's very
interesting
yes for sure
and also I I'm currently doing in
December a programming Challenge and for
one day uh someone just um asked this
bot to to solve this problem like uh
read read the pro program Challenge and
then write some code and then solve the
problem and it got first place like it
made it in 10 seconds so I think this is
really a game changer
um yeah of artificial intelligence but
it absolutely is Raj here thank you for
the call yes super interesting check it
out email me if you find some
interesting stuff you could do with it
let's go to our friend Edo from Rome or
is it Edo Edo or Edo Ido
uh hi David can you hear me yes I can
uh welcome to the program how are things
in Rome
uh they're fine it's a little bit rainy
and uh you know uh we now have a new
right-wing government
um so
who knows what a future holds for us yes
very much so
yeah I I wanted to ask you you know I
I've been following uh since Trump's
election American politics and uh I'd
say that
people like Christian Cinema and uh
Mansion aren't they really just you know
more like the public figures for you
know Democratic conservatism in the
sense that even if they went away
magically uh Democrats reached a
majority to abolish the filibuster you
would suddenly have other people
standing up and saying uh this is maybe
not such a good idea
I think that there is a great extent to
which you are absolutely correct yeah I
do think that that is there are people
who by their nature
are they want to be in a particular
position of saying hey you know what I'm
going to kind of put a limit here I'm
going to be the limiter and I'm going to
be the road through which all
legislation must go and I'm going to
take this position of enlightened
centrism which is sort of a pejorative
yeah I think to some degree there's a
tendency that someone always will want
to play that role I I do think so
okay thank you David uh I wanted to say
just another little thing sure um do you
know that uh Rupert Murdoch is actually
active in my country and the funny thing
is
um here is Media Corporation is actually
quite moderate yes compared to because
um right-wing media has always been
almost a monopoly of Berlusconi so when
murder came to Italy he found his own
niche in you know moderate uh uh
centrism even left-wing to some people
yes that's interesting yeah I mean I
think
it is not shocking to me that the
murdochs are active in many more
countries than people might assume that
makes sense to me
ah um uh did you really last thing did
you hear about the nuclear fusion
breakthrough you know I did hear about
it I have I can't say I fully understand
exactly what the Breakthrough is I plan
to do some reading on it this weekend
when I have some time
I see uh well say thank you very much
David my pleasure great to hear from our
Italian friends of course